So there are still questions you want to ask me.
There are yes.
Just like last time, go ahead and introduce yourself the name of the date.
Oh yes.
My name is Kenneth Hedberg.
This is the 29th of September of 2011.
Okay.
So last time we pretty much finished up with Caltech,
but one thing I realized that throughout the ask you about
was any memories you have a day to have a day to have a day to have.
Of it all.
Yeah.
Only peripheral leave because I saw it together where there was
been fairly frequently.
Excuse me.
And she, of course, is always present at the open houses that they held occasionally.
These open houses.
Some of the faculty and so on were invited, not for many of the students.
I saw her there.
And I saw her a lot, of course, later on when she and mine
as came to Oregon State.
But at the time that I was at Caltech, I saw her with mine as a great deal.
And that's about all.
When did you make the use of the OSU and what did you decide to make that move?
When did I come to OSU or what?
Well, I don't know.
Have I mentioned it all?
The circumstances under which I experience the opening here.
The open.
At Oregon State?
No, no.
Oh, well, I had been working at Caltech for many years after my
doctorate.
And, well, many five or six.
And I was actively engaged in research.
And I was stopped in the hole one day by Carl Neeman, who was a distinguished,
organic chemist.
The new mine knew quite well.
They said, can I receive the letter from a former colleague of mine?
I went to graduate school with at Wisconsin.
Who is now at Oregon State?
And he said, they have an opening there.
They wondered whether I had anybody who would be interested.
Or we here at Caltech is anybody who might be interested.
I just thought I'd mention it to you in passing because I remember that you were in Oregon State
undergrad.
So, at this time, my wife was pretty unhappy in California in Barcelona because of the
air pollution.
Our first son was, our son was about to be born and she won a raising in that environment.
So, I said, yes, I'd better explore this.
And so, I wrote them to E.C. Gilbert, who wrote back, then they did have an opening.
And one thing followed another, and it turned out that my wife and I were going to drive north
to Oregon to visit my parents who lived at that time in Australia.
And I said to Gilbert that I would stop on route and talk with him in members of the faculty
and discuss the opening.
Then I got another letter from a guy named Bill Calville, will you be called well?
Well, let me know on certain terms that the reason this was a job was because he had managed
to get the president of the University AL Strand to commit to new faculty hires and chemistry.
And it turns out that at that time, well, let me put it this way.
Gilbert and Bill Calville were not on the best of terms.
Gilbert was a department chairman and he told well was a professor who did almost,
did no research on site, but had some mining claims and other things.
Kind of a more open, free-handed backslopping type, a member of the country club,
and a new AL Strand fairly well.
And he complained that the freshman at Oregon State and incoming students were not being given proper
instruction because the weren't enough professorial stuff involved in this,
just graduated teaching assistants and so on.
And he managed to can Instagram that perhaps there should be some positions set up.
And these would people, of course, would be nominally responsible to call those
since he was running the whole program.
And the main purpose of the main task of these people were going to be that they would sort of
ride herd on all the teaching assistants.
They would patrol the laboratories, make sure that the teaching assistants were doing their job.
They would, of course, have some responsibilities themselves, bought in the freshman program.
And they would be, in this way, and be responsible for laboratories.
And then, as I mentioned, patrol the laboratories regularly.
So I immediately sensed that there was something, there was a bit of,
what an adversarial relationship between Gilbert and Cole.
Well, on Gilbert, of course, is interested in hiring somebody who could also increase the
research potential of the faculty.
Cole wasn't in the least interested in whether these guys could do any research or not.
He just wanted them as sort of major domals.
And so I learned all of this in more detail when I came and talked with Gilbert and
talked with told well.
And I also had no numerous conversations with other members of the faculty,
people who have passed on now, Tom Norris,
Wendell Slaball, everybody that was on the faculty that I had known before.
And after concluding all these interviews, we drove on down to my terrace,
came back to California.
So Gilbert, who was still a guy who was officially in charge of the hiring.
And then I would think it over and I'd let him know.
So after I got back to Pasadena, I thought for a long time about this.
I'm decided that the conditions of this job were such that I found it unliked
but to be able to get my research program going at Oregon State in a reasonable length of
time.
So I declined the offer, which was $5,500 for nine months or nine months,
but spread over ten months.
Well, my wife was very unhappy about this because she liked Oregon.
More like Oslo, where she grew up in Norway.
And she put it there was a water in the river, so I put Norris again in trees in the forest.
So she couldn't see that in LA.
We drove across a bridge one place.
So I pointed out to her that this was the San Gabriel river.
She looked down there was no water.
It was just to go like the dry was.
And we went through the San Gabriel forest on the outskirts.
So there's nothing but sage, bro.
That's the source of work on that.
At any rate, she was very unhappy about this.
And a few days later I got a call from Gilbert saying he was very sorry to receive my letter.
He was very much hoped that I would accept the job.
And he said he wondered if they were able to increase the starting
so I'll read a little bit what I reconsider.
And I said at this time, home life was a little frosty because at least it was so disappointed.
So I said, okay, I'll do that.
If I told you any of this at all, no, okay.
So the offer came back and he said we can pay you two or three hundred dollars more per year.
That's maybe five percent or six percent increase.
And so I asked Paul, what he thought about all of this.
And he invited me to come up to his home one evening after hours five o'clock or so.
Can't remember exactly.
So I went up to 4,500 per point.
Whatever the street number is or yeah, he's awesome.
You said I'm up around to discuss the job.
I've been very active in research at Caltech.
And a number of published papers, lots of things going.
And I expressed to him, my fear that I was going not going to be able to get my research program going
at Oregon State because it involved the construction of apparatus.
You saw that apparatus.
I had to build that by hand.
There were extremely limited machine shop facilities.
Nothing in the chemistry department at all.
And I didn't see how I could get that instrument built as Oregon State.
So I expressed all this to him and then told him that the actual number of hours that I was expected to be in contact with students
was something like 15 or 16 hours a week.
Just in the hands-on contact,
that's about 30% or a little bit more than that.
35% of the total time, not counting preparation or anything in that side.
And falling, sort of lean back and his chair was sitting inside by side looking out over the valley.
And the swimming pool.
He says, well, he says, I don't know.
He says 15 hours.
He says, well, I was at Oregon State.
I was teaching 40 hours a week.
That was the year that he was a sophomore.
And had been asked to handle the course for young women in home economics.
I think it was taking chemistry as a requirement.
That's where he met his wife, either Helen.
But anyway, that's the story, you know.
So anyhow, he said 40 hours, he says, I don't know.
He said, I think that Oregon State will not be a first class institution for research in my time.
And probably not in yours.
These are his words.
He says, on the other hand, that's not really important in a bigger sense.
He says, if you didn't get your program going,
you'll be very happy there.
Oregon is a wonderful place to live as you and I know.
He says, I don't know.
I think it might be worthwhile giving a chance.
I think you could make it go on.
You'd be very happy there.
So with that encouragement, I told Gilbert up and said, yes, I would accept the offer.
And my wife, of course, was delighted at this because at this time,
our son had just been born.
And we lived in Pasadena, a down below, not far from Caltech.
And the small grid roll in the morning about 11 o'clock,
and she'd take the baby in, close all the doors and windows.
Keep them closed all about four and they have to know.
When the winds reverse their directions swept all the small back out to see again.
And she'd get open things up.
It was pretty hot too, so I had a hose in this garden cottage
that I put on the route and turn on the water to keep it cool.
During the time that she was so to speak incarcerated.
Anyway, that fall.
I told Gilbert that I wouldn't be able to come in the fall,
by the fall term, but I could come January 1st.
This was January 1st was 1956, so this is all in 1955.
This conversation went up.
So, come January, we drove north after Christmas in times of a huge storm
that actually led to flooding.
This is a fine way for my life to be introduced to the worst Puerto Vallas.
You don't know anything today about how it was then,
but we drove up to Eugene, got the junction city,
and it turned out that the 99 West was closed
because of water and the roads.
But there was a bus going up 99 East to Albany,
and I, with our car, the baby in the back,
can be said, we followed this bus very carefully up,
sometimes water almost up to the hubcaps of the car,
got to Albany, and then it turned out that the road from Albany
to Corvallas was okay.
It wasn't underwater yet, but the road from Corvallas south
on 99 West was underwater.
So we met and why that we managed to get the Corvallas
and by free arrangement we had run out of the house,
of a faculty member that was going to be away for three months.
So we had a place to move into immediately,
all furnished very nice house,
um, sentimenty,
uh, over there against the hill and salt,
uh, well, you know what it is.
Um, it's very nice.
And turned out that everything was flooded
the following day or two in Corvallas.
You could hardly get around it all,
and then it turned cold later on,
and snow came and so on.
So that was my introduction to Corvallas.
I showed up to work on one of the early days,
and Gilbert told me all they had a,
a kind of a bonus to give me.
And that was that I was going to be, uh,
assigned a teacher course in a graduate course in physical chemistry
to, uh, to, uh, organic chemist largely on others.
Well, this sounded like a bonus to him,
but for somebody just coming there,
I mean this is a lecture three hours a week,
and I had never done this course before.
So I had all those lecture notes to prepare,
as well as the stuff I was expected to do under Bill Coldwell's, uh,
uh, regime.
So I had a very, very busy time and with a newborn
in the house of my wife, you know, trying hard to,
the customer self to life and a new place with a new baby,
and a husband who was up to his ears and work
wasn't very easy.
I, uh, but pretty discouraged at the end of that term,
and, uh, as a term to run,
I took care of you right down on, uh,
a piece of paper divided into days and hours of the day
for a week, each week.
How much time I was actually spending
in duties connected with teaching,
by connected with that man,
in the, in the students one-on-one preparation,
including evening hours and everything else,
and I was averaging that first term,
fifty-six hours a week,
only in teaching related duties.
And so my fears about getting my programs started on the research side,
well, well, born out by that first experience.
And of course, I was expected not only to have a program
during getting my research going,
but I had to build this apparatus,
which meant that I had to design it,
sit down with, uh,
I think I showed you just briefly,
folders of those drawings in there.
I had a drawing table in my office,
and so I spent a lot of time with drawing these things,
and then Professor Junker in physics,
I had a fine physics shop,
and I went across to see him,
and he agreed,
he saved my life actually,
to allow one of the people in physics,
I think they had through a form of shenus,
who would be assigned to my job,
and he would do everything,
and he and I would be on one-to-one contact all the time.
He reserved the right to retake this man
for any projects that physics needed, of course,
since he was employed by physics,
and using the physics facilities,
and that worked out just beautifully.
Took a long time to get the apparatus built
through four years,
but it was finally done and put together
and we managed to make it go.
So, that Junker's facilities and his kindness
really are responsible for getting me off the ground
in Oregon State.
So, would you describe the advance a little bit for me?
Sorry.
describe the apparatus for me.
Oh, well, the apparatus is what is called
an electron defraction unit.
It consists of the essential feature of it
is an electron gun that will produce
a well-colonated beam of electrons
at the potential of about 60 kilobiles.
So, it's a very energetic beam
on the scale of the way chemistry operates.
That beam is admitted into a large vacuum chamber
in my apparatus, the whole thing is mounted vertically,
so the beam comes down into this vacuum chamber,
and at the bottom of the beam,
let's say, is a detecting beam,
which is in my case, photographic film,
and those those photographic plates,
but it's no photographic film,
and this photographic film is eight by ten inches square
and is perpendicular to the beam
and is moved into position by mechanism
that I built into the apparatus.
And the apparatus is designed to study
the structures of molecules and the gas phase
by diffracting this beam of electrons from them.
So, we have a long nozzle that protrudes
into the apparatus with a tip that passes
that stops just about a millimeter short
and where there's very fine high-power
electron beam is coming down.
Now, if in this nozzle, which is a two
with a fine tip on it,
you admit a gas into the chamber,
the gas shoots out the nozzle tip,
intersects the electron beam at right angles
and produces what is called a diffraction pattern.
This diffraction pattern consists of what happens
is, of course, it's recorded on this photographic film
at the underneath the nozzle
and perpendicular to the beam.
So, the diffraction pattern is recorded on this
in a set of diffuse rings of varying intensity
and the spacing of these rings
and their shapes of the pattern
contain all the structural information
about the length of the inter atomic distances
in the molecule.
And so, we take these patterns and we analyze
and then out of that, we can deduce the
intimate details of the structures
of these molecules in the gas phase
that is essentially, it's a structure of a single molecule
because so far apart,
they don't interact with one another
as they shoot into the apparatus.
And so, that's what I was charged with
or what I wanted to build
and which I found we got going.
So, all those errors.
It's still running and rough.
Yeah, and it is running
and right now, and running beautifully,
we just did an experiment last week.
Beautiful patterns we got for a new molecule
or interested in.
It doesn't take long for the experiment
as quite interesting.
The technique is developed enormously
since the days when I first entered the field
at Caltech as a graduate student.
And now, the experiment that lasts
is diffraction pattern.
You expose the photographic film
to the diffraction pattern
for only two or three minutes
and you might want to make five different films
or ten different films.
So, all told you can do the entire experiment
in a day if you push it.
Everything.
And that's all the day to you need
for what might be for a graduate student
a year and a half of work analyzing it.
So, the apparatus mostly sits on use
because we can quickly gather all the day to we knew.
So, I've had a lot of visitors who have come
used the apparatus.
And if I had a technician,
I could supply all the diffraction data
every group in the world.
This technician did nothing
but take diffraction pictures
of the substances involved.
Now, maybe a little more complicated
because these are gas phase molecules
we admit them in the chamber as a gas.
But that doesn't mean that they have to be a gas
as you look at them.
You can put them on the table.
The fact is you've got to get them
to the gas phase in order to make this experiment work.
Well, we have a sort of ovens
and heated nozzle so we can heat these things up
and get the vapor C60
that we've worked on.
Of course, it's very intractable
as no vapor pressure at all is because
so we had to heat this substance
in an oven to 800
and some of degrees Celsius
in order to get the tiniest bit of vapor from it.
But that was sufficient to give us a diffraction pattern
and we were able to determine the structure
of this material which is a carbon-like powder
on the table.
So, we have all sorts of exiliar apparatus
which allows us to produce gas molecules
from lots of different circumstances.
So, it works very nicely.
I'm very happy with it.
I should add as a...
as a...
Postgriptol is that this technique
was very powerful
through the 40s and 50s and 60s
even in the 70s.
But there are other techniques
that have developed in the meantime too
and so there are fewer and fewer laboratories
in the world doing this work.
When I came to Oregon State and got mine going
there were about...
there were only two laboratories
in the United States
that this kind of worked mine
and a laboratory at Michigan.
There were other people who...
Well, there was another apparatus built.
It didn't...
It worked for a while, but not very long.
And there was one of Texas that was built,
similar to that.
But it was built in the physics department
and the interest there was not the same as the interest
but chemisown.
And so, it worked for a while
and then it stopped.
And later on, there were apparatus
in Britain.
There was one in Edinburgh.
And later on,
and still, Extant is one in Reading England.
There was one in Germany.
They were very active in Germany.
And when I first started, there was one in Belgium
and one in Holland.
And several, in at that time, the Soviet Union.
And two or three laboratories in Japan.
All of them had apparatus and could do experiments.
All of those are gone except the apparatus in Reading.
The apparatus in Germany, by the way,
the man who was the professor who was in charge
of that laboratory retired.
His name was Heinz Oberhommer.
And his apparatus has been transferred to an
inorganic chemist who is using it as kind of an
exiduary to his main work,
which is the preparation and interesting inorganic compounds.
And as a part of that, he wants to know what the structures are.
The apparatus in Reading is still Extant.
But the man who was in charge of it before
has now retired.
And the woman that was working with him
has a permanent position at the University.
But she's heavily involved with teaching
and has very little time to work with it.
There were two important laboratories in Norway.
I didn't mention them earlier.
Both of them are now gone as far as apparatus is concerned.
There isn't any further support for it in that
in science decisions are always made about where you're going to put
a limited amount of phones.
And in Norway, it's now determined that this particular area of
research will not be supported anymore by the University.
In the sense that they will hire technicians and
professorial rank people to do this kind of work.
And I share that will probably be the case here at Oregon State, too.
So we don't know.
It's plain fact is it's not judged by what's going on
in the world of chemistry today.
Cutting his stuff.
A lot of the things that's going on today
isn't shifted more into larger molecule biological
biological things, synthetic organic chemistry,
new material, things of that sort, and not the kind of basic science
that I was involved with for all those years.
So anyway, I came to Oregon State,
got a built and I've been here ever since
doing with this kind of research.
That's what it's all about.
And great fun.
So what were the techniques that you used to analyze the
direction patterns?
Well, yes, that's a good question.
I don't know how much of the technology I ought to
go into.
But essentially, you're faced with this photographic film.
If you hold it up to the light, you see this beautiful pattern of
circular rings of varying intensity, very diffuse,
easily recognized, going out from a central point.
And all the information about the structure of the molecules
contained, as I said earlier, in the spaceings and the shapes of
these rings.
The question that you're really asking is how do you go from that
to determine how a molecule was put together?
Well, it turns out that these rings are related to the structure of
the molecule by some according to theory by a rather simple way.
I'll keep it as simple as a possibly count.
Every inter-atomic distance in the molecule creates
an effect on this film, a pattern that consists of nothing more than a
sine wave, going from the middle out.
Now a sine wave just goes up and down, up and down, up and down,
all the way out to the end of the photographic plate.
So if you have a die-accompanied molecule, all the rings in their
intensity would look like a sine wave, just from the beginning,
up, down, up, down, the spacing would be identical between them,
aside from some geometric factors that I don't have to go into.
So all you have to do is to measure the frequency, oh,
I should say that the farther apart, the two atoms are
that are giving rise to this sine wave, the greater the frequency of the
sine wave.
So two atoms that are far apart like this give a sine wave that goes up and
down very rapidly, two atoms that are very close together will give a
sine wave that has a very long wavelength.
So you'll see very few rings.
So all you'd have to do is to measure the spacing between these
rings and that is related by theory to how far apart the atoms are.
Now that's for a die-accompanied, let's say that's the case for a
die-accompanied molecule, you only have one sine wave.
The die-accompanied molecule vibrates, and so the atoms are not
rigid, they're moving back and forth away from one another like two
moles on a spring.
And of course that means that the distance is in constant.
Well it turns out according to theory to a good approximation.
This sine wave instead of having constant amplitude all the way up,
dies off due to this vibration.
So you measure the dying off of the sine wave and that tells you how
big the amplitude of this vibration is.
So we learn about two things.
The distances between the atoms on the average and we learn about how
much they're moving with respect to one another by measuring the
damping off of the sine wave.
Well of course there aren't many die-accompanied molecules left
to study, but every that problem or rather the theory that I
mentioned applies to just the pairs of atoms.
So if you have a molecule that has more than just two atoms in it,
you're going to have more than two distances, more than one distance.
Every pair of atoms in the molecule gives rise to one of these sine
waves.
So carbon dioxide is a linear molecule, is a carbon oxygen bond,
and that gives rise to a single sine wave that goes out.
There are two of them, but they have exactly the same distance,
so there are two sine waves that are right on top of one another.
Then you have the distance between the oxygen atoms,
and that's twice as big.
So it generates a sine wave also, which has a frequency,
twice as great to first approximation,
as the frequency in the carbon oxygen,
because the distance is twice as long.
And that gives a sine wave that oscillates with twice the frequency
in the first one, and they're on top of one another.
So the pattern is no longer a simple sine wave,
but a collection of two sine waves.
If you know how to separate out these sine waves and measure their
frequencies, then you know exactly what the structure of this molecule is.
So I'll see you'll two were bent, like NL2 is,
NL2 would be entirely similar,
but there you would find the distances between the oxygen atoms,
is not twice the distance between the nitrogen and oxygen,
because it's a triangular molecule, like this.
So that oxygen oxygen distance would not be moving
as twice the frequency of the NL, but less than that.
So you can immediately determine that distance,
and determine the nitrogen oxygen distance,
and by comparing them, you know what the bound angle is in the molecule.
This simple account can be applied to molecules that are very, very complicated.
The entire problem, man, is just to separate out what these different sine waves are.
Construct yourself a model that will account for all of the distances,
and then you have the structure of the molecule.
It is, in practice, considerably more complicated than I'm telling you,
but that's essentially the features of the whole thing.
Now, you asked how we do this.
Well, we have to measure the frequencies,
and to do that, we have a scanner,
what is called a micro-densitometer.
The film is placed on the bed of this micro-densitometer,
and the film, in the apparatus that I have,
we have a mechanism that rotates the film around its center.
The purpose of this is that you are averaging the information around the entire circle.
If the densitometer consists of a beam that passes through the film,
and a detector that measures how intense the light beam is as it comes through the film.
So in the ring is intense, the light beam that comes through is much reduced,
and when the film is very more transparent,
the beam that comes through there is more intense.
So you get a recording of the blackness of the film.
So this thing translates,
and we have electronic data accumulation system
that measures the intensity of the blackness of the film
as a function from the center outward.
And that gives us digital data,
and that's what we actually work with to analyze.
So that's essentially it,
and without having given the laboratory for a week,
I can't tell you much more that we're making clear here, I don't think.
So what are any other questions about that?
How have you decided which modules did this study?
Yeah, well, this largely comes from your own,
in my case, my own interests, let's say,
or the principal investigators interest.
Now, if we take C60, for example,
that was big news at the time it was discovered.
And I had a former student named Bob Johnson,
who was working at IBM in San Jose.
And they had managed to create or had a sample of this stuff.
Now, in the beginning, it was very rare.
I mean, a few, well, you could get it in
in milligram quantities.
And I, the sample, I actually worked at,
I think, had 300 milligrams in it.
And it was a little bit of black powder in a while.
And at doing market prices,
that was $5,000 worth of sample.
Well, Bob wrote to me, and he asked me,
how could we do this?
Could you do this work?
I said, well, no, I'm very exciting.
We should try.
And so they supplied the sample.
Several people in IBM and were involved in this project
and leasing me up here.
And so we got the sample and we managed to,
it was very exciting because I didn't know
whether we were going to be able to get a pattern
from this stuff at all.
Because it was so refractory.
You know, we had to heat it so hot.
And the other, we had it.
And with so hot, I was going red in the apparatus.
Now fortunately, the film that we use is not very sensitive
to red light.
Secondly, I was able to build a shield around them all,
or it protected the film from almost all of the glow.
As I heated it up, I could see it glowing.
Bright red in there.
And then I would close up the window to the apparatus
and turn off the beam, lecture on beam,
and quickly move the plate in position.
Open up the beam and expose this.
I could not see evidence of any, we have a fluorescent screen
in there that we can see patterns on for most molecules.
At the time we did the experiment,
I couldn't see anything on this fluorescent screen
other than a very faint glow from the screen.
So I didn't know whether we were getting anything or not.
And so we made two or three of these exposures.
And I took the film into the dark room,
and I couldn't believe my eyes when I saw a beautiful pattern
was you couldn't predict it.
It would be like that.
Or that you would even get one from seeing
there was no evidence.
Normally when I run stuff on the apparatus,
I put the main beam through a slot in a fluorescent screen
so I can see the scattering all around it.
And I can see it just, it'll look like this on a black thing
somewhat reduced.
I can see we're getting scattering.
Couldn't see that with C60.
And yet there it was.
And I'm absolutely beautiful pattern.
It was very exciting.
Anybody got a complicated analysis?
Was it what?
Well, it turns out.
Bucky balls, if you pick up a soccer ball,
and you look to see how the things are put together,
there are hexagons in it,
and pentagons in it.
And they're put together in a completely symmetric way.
And it turns out that in Bucky balls
are on a soccer thing,
the length of the stitching
in a soccer ball.
Yeah, it's a little hard to describe,
but there are bonds that link two six-member patches together
and stitches that link a six-member to a five-member.
And those two bond lengths are different in C60 itself.
Those are the only two parameters
that are necessary to determine the structure of C60,
assuming that it is a soccer ball.
That's the assumption that you make,
and that was well characterized by NMR
spectrum and other things.
So we knew it was a soccer ball type,
but we didn't know what the length of these bonds were.
So if you then have the only thing that changes
that doesn't change the shape,
it only changes the size of the six-member
and the five-member ring,
as you change the length of these bonds.
Well, we had to put together a model,
that is to say that you see what you actually do
and analysis, you have the experimental pattern,
and then you have to generate a model
and compare the pattern that this model gives
with the one that you experience experimentally.
So you are fitting a model for which you have calculated a pattern,
and you adjust that pattern to fit the experiment
by changing the parameters of a model.
So to make this applying this to C60,
the pattern depends only on the relative length
of those two distances that I mentioned.
The one between six-member rings
and the one between a six-member ring.
And so my wife then put together the model,
and you can imagine it's not easy.
You have to remember,
generate every distance in the molecule
from just these two parameters.
There are 720 distances in the molecule,
and she constructed a program
that would calculate this model for us.
And that was the one we used and tested,
and that led finally to the fitting and the structure of the thing.
And we published that in science,
a couple of decades ago now, I guess.
There is lots of fun.
I wanted to ask also about denonence of glory.
Which one?
Denonence of glory.
We never actually finished the structure of that thing,
because a friend of mine at the University of Michigan
had done a very good job,
and he was an head of us.
We worked on other xenon compounds.
We did xenon tetroxide,
which is four oxygen atoms,
arranged in the form of a tetrahedron around a xenon atom.
And that was a quite an experience,
because a very explosive compound,
we had several minor explosions,
but you couldn't,
we had to generate the compound on the apparatus,
by adding acid to a
a prezenate as it's called,
a compound which contains xenon with the,
but it's a salt.
And we had to build an apparatus
where we could tip this up slightly,
and add acid to this,
where upon the xenon tetroxide
would be formed,
and could flow into our apparatus through our nozzle.
There were several times,
the stuff in our gas phase is very unstable.
We had several times,
very minor explosions,
and minor in the sense that,
there was no danger to anybody involved here,
but it blew holes in our conducting line right away.
So we had that happen several times.
That's the only xenon compound
that we actually finished the structure of,
the xenon tetroxide.
Were there other compounds there,
and could they memorable or be waiting?
Well,
the ones that we've talked about
are one sort of in the public eye.
So,
I think in terms of public interest
of something very novel,
probably not so much.
The work that we do,
I've always tended to characterize
in the term used in the old days,
which is basic research.
And I had no really discernible
practical applications,
but it was fundamental stuff,
and there are a lot of fundamental problems
in chemistry.
For example,
chemistry has it as practiced
at some level or another,
makes continuous and intimate use
of the concept of the structure
of the things you're dealing with.
I mean,
we talked about the structure of proteins, for example.
We talked about the structure of almost everything,
an organic chemistry structure
is when electures on the board.
So we were involved in determining structures,
but what we were doing
is actually measuring these structures
to very high precision.
We're not just making a ball and stick drawing.
We're looking at the distances between the atoms
and trying to deduce from this,
how these distances
might be related to the reactivity
of the molecule and things of that sort.
How the intimate details of the structure
distances,
well let me put it this way,
size and shape of the molecule
are related to this reactivity.
I can give you one example of this.
That most people don't know about,
but a very common chemical compound
in nature is nitrogen dioxide that comes from
combustion of internal engines under high temperatures
and so on.
Well nitrogen dioxide is a triangular molecule
with a nitrogen that they apex.
And two of these nitrogen oxins nitrogen dioxide molecules
come together in a form of tetramer.
I mean a dimer that has
it's called di nitrogen tetroxide.
Now a remarkable thing of this
is that these two molecules come together
and fall apart, come together and fall apart
just so easily.
If you have N02 in the gas phase,
you have N204 in the gas phase also.
As you change the temperature and pressure,
the amount of one of these
with respect to the other changes.
Well, N204 is very hard to
it falls apart so easily.
It's very hard to measure.
Structure on it.
But we undertook that job.
And the way it was done
is that we got a sample of N02
and the reaction for the decomposition
or dimersation or de-diamersation
is extremely rapid.
It just flows apart immediately
or comes together immediately.
Well, if you cool it down,
the stream down.
What happens is you get
more and more of N204
as you heat it up.
All of this is decomposed right away
because of the thermal effects.
So what we did was cool a sample
to the oven.
I mean sorry, the nozzle way way down.
Well, way down below zero
of Celsius.
Run the stuff through it
and we got beautiful pictures of N204.
Then we heated it up a little bit
and we could see all the characteristic distances
for that molecule beginning to disappear
as if the higher we heated it,
the less of those we had.
We got it to 100 and some on degrees
there's nothing but N02 present.
Well, the structure of N204
turns out to be very interesting.
It turns out that there is an extraordinarily long
NN bond.
The bonds between atoms in typical compounds
tend to be more or less the same.
For example, saturated hydrocarbons
have carbon carbon bonds and I can tell you right away
they will be 1.54 or 1.535 angstroms
to within 100 of an angstrom
in no matter what compound you look at.
Well, there's a characteristic NN bond
2 and NO bonds.
And it turned out that this NN bond
was very, very long.
So much so that by a simple criteria
that line is falling in the degrees one time,
it's only in the order of a tenth
as strong as a normal single bond.
So that accounts for about 4 to 4 days away.
But one thing this characteristic of single bonds
is that the two ends of a molecule
can rotate around like this.
You see, they're not fixed like this
because of the bond as a week.
To our intense surprise, that's not the case of N204.
It's a flat, plain or molecule,
no matter how long this bond is.
So what is it that holds a flat, you see?
Well, that's not a single bond
don't hold things flat.
Why is this flat?
Well, that was the interesting question of the time.
And it turns out that the structure
of the N02 part of the N204 molecule
is almost identically that of the separated N02.
That is bringing the two together
to make the dimer doesn't change the structure
of the ends of all.
Normally, if you bring them together,
if you take two monomers and you bring them together,
these will change somewhat in angles and distances,
not with N204.
But these are puzzles that are just lots of fun
to think about, that's all.
And so this kind of research
is the thing that's characterized
what these and I have done most of our career here.
We have all sorts of different systems that pose different
basic chemical questions.
And we look at molecules to try to find out
what we can learn about these basic chemical questions,
answers to them from studying the structures
of maybe even a series of several molecules
that have other some things in common,
some things different to see how the differences
are going to affect properties of the molecules.
So that's what we do.
So you've got your apparatus constructed
and do I have to send it to your teaching world
to decrease some?
Oh.
Well, in due course,
and those days the chemistry department
consisted of four divisions.
There was organic, inorganic,
physical, and analytical.
They were pretty clearly defined.
People were in these divisions in accordance
with the kind of research they did.
Well, there came an opening in physical chemistry
and Gilbert this chairman told me immediately
that when that opening a card
he was going to move me into that division.
Well, this was two or three years later.
The other, oh, by the two jobs were filled
that this monitoring of the laboratories
that brought me here called roles.
Efforts.
The other person was Tom Parsons.
Tom Parsons was in chemistry for a while,
but moved into administration
and finishes career in areas in the ministerial.
Well, that I moved into physical chemistry,
Gilbert, and I became a physical chemist
and my teaching responsibilities has changed a lot.
I no longer wrote heard on TAs,
but I still taught general chemistry,
but I also began to teach courses regularly
in physical chemistry.
So my contact hours went down,
but the amount of time I spent working
certainly didn't, because now I had
the contact hour before
we're just, you know, I knew the experiments
and freshman chemistry the kids were doing,
and I could walk through and make sure
that they were getting a proper attention
and so on, but now I had to prepare lectures
and in courses that I hadn't lectured in before.
But the contact hours went down,
but the amount of time spent teaching
didn't diminish for quite a while.
But nevertheless, my apparatus was coming along
and I was very lucky when I came here
because I had all the money I needed to build this.
I got some money from the research corporation
before I arrived.
I applied for that at Caltech,
and I came with a Sloan foundation grant
which was five years of money
that I used for summer support,
and I wasn't teaching,
and then I could do it fully
to drawing up parts from my apparatus and so on.
And then I got NSF support too,
so I never lacked for funding
the main thing I've had trouble with
is the time in the early days,
not in the later days.
So things have turned out later days
that teaching loads gradually began
to fall into a...
I don't want to put it.
A range that was consistent
with what we were being taught
at other institutions
with which we competed at that time.
So there was still a lot of teaching,
but it was of a kind that really lots of fun.
What was the environment like in the Department of Education?
Oh, it was very collegial.
Collegial was that the word.
We were all very friendly with one another.
I mean,
socially,
I had friends in physical chemistry
and organic chemistry,
and we saw one another
at analytical chemistry of dinner parties.
We did lots of things together.
New Year's Eve parties and so on.
So it was,
in my opinion,
a lot more cohesive than it is at the moment.
And at the time,
a lot more cohesive at Oregon State
than in many institutions.
In many institutions,
there is a kind of a very wary attitude
or outlook
from one divisional type to another.
And sometimes even within the members of the division,
have to realize that
university teaching
university careers can be very competitive,
especially those that depend
to good deal on research that you do,
as well as on your teaching.
And so,
you read about this all the time of the press
of people that are competing for
even publicly sometimes for priority
and some major discovery.
But we never had any of that in chemistry.
We just had a very good time.
That's been a fine place.
I'm sorry.
That was a history that is very interesting.
Lisa decided,
did I mention how we mapped?
Yeah, well.
When we came to the stage,
she was the scientist,
and we worked together at Caltech.
She was actually paid at Caltech.
And we worked in the lecture under fraction.
They are both of us together in the same project.
Did several things are.
Then when we came to Oregon,
she was very busy,
of course, with our son,
who was only three months old when we arrived.
So she did no work at all at that point.
Except.
Well, that's not quite true because we did manage
to find some babysitting for a few hours a day
now and then when she came to the university.
But she was never away from home more than two or three hours
at a time then.
And that a couple of years later,
our daughter was born.
So then we had two kids at home.
And so by and large, she worked only sporadically
until the kids got into nursery school
when she could then drive them up to,
they were on orchard street here in the University of
University School, which has changed its location,
I think, somewhat.
But the kids would go there.
And she would come to the laboratory
and then when there's such an issue,
she'd take them up to home.
And we live very close to the Jefferson School.
So until both of them got into school,
she was home most of the time.
But managed to put in several hours per week
working on our projects at that time.
Then when the kids went to Jefferson School,
she could, in the morning,
and the kids would get dressed.
I'd go off to work.
Kids would get dressed.
School would start.
They would run out the front door, go over to school
and we'd let the teachers know what phone to call.
Then Lisa would get in the her car and drive over
the University and we would work until about
two or three years old.
When she would get in the car and go home,
park the car and get in the house.
The kids would run out of the school and come back.
They never knew.
She actually worked because of the forest.
They were concerned.
She was there.
When they left and there when they came home.
But she was able to work about half time then.
She was paid by a line on them.
In the budget for grants,
lives exceeded and getting.
And then we also had joint grants.
And then she's very good at mathematics.
And she was hired as a,
by the computer center to be working on.
She was very good at programming and so on.
And she was kind of a liaison with chemistry and programming
in the computer center.
And so we still had centralized computing.
Then we had one rhubarb.
I might as well tell you this.
I haven't before.
But it went something like this.
Gilbert had retired.
And Bart Christensen had become chairman.
And Lisa had been working on my grant for the
line item and the budget for her salary.
And the proposal that had been department chairman
have to sign up for proposal and.
And so it was funded.
And then he decided one time that.
She could no longer work on the grant after her.
After the present year was over academic year.
And so she wrote him a letter and pointed out that she had.
Item for a salary was never explained what the reason was.
And he responded and she wrote again and he didn't respond.
It turned out in retrospect that he was greatly afraid.
That there would be some negative feeling about.
A man and wife working together.
In the chemistry department.
Because at that time there were.
I was not on herdo.
But it was a little unusual.
The thing on she was not being paid on state funds at all.
And she was an expert on the field.
And which there were no other.
West on the Mississippi.
You see.
Well.
He persisted in this.
So we finally went over to.
Together to the.
Dean.
Who was virtual on.
At that time.
And.
Said.
I knew him very well from years.
I said, we're in look.
This is a situation.
He said, well, why didn't you tell me this before.
I said, well, this Lisa said this to you know.
Well, we were going through channels.
Our issue was not with you.
So he looked at this and he says, well, he says.
She can certainly work on the grant.
The proposal, mother, I had been signed by Bert.
And now he was refusing to continue her funding even though he has signed the agreement.
So he overturned this.
But then he said.
If Lisa wants to work in the future, she'll have to have her name on the grant.
Not just worked on your grant.
Well, I can't remember much of the details following that.
But it turned out that.
Prisons one was about to retire.
There were circumstances here that I don't need to go into.
But anyway, he was going to retire.
And a new one man was going to come.
And I was on a national committee at the time.
And I was a former friend of mine at Caltech named Dave Schumacher.
It was on the same committee.
And Dave and I mentioned to him.
He was from Idaho, of course.
And going to recolage.
We've gone to Caltech together.
You finished a little earlier than I did.
That's a day.
Would you, we need a new department, Sherman.
He was chairman of the committee.
I was on I saw how good he was at a ministering thing.
Would you, of by any criteria, even consider coming back.
Maybe being considered as our department chairman.
And there was a lot of talk about this.
He decided that, yes, he might like that.
He was at MIT at the time.
So we invited him out.
And he was off for the job.
And he liked Oregon.
And he went to school in Portland.
But one of the criteria for him coming was that his wife would be able to work.
Here was another man on wife team.
She was a cross-logger for his he was.
And McFicker was the chairman of this time.
And one of the conditions for him coming was that his wife would be allowed to work.
And then he said, oh, by the way, he says, you know, can't at least they have the same problem.
And so McFicker came around today.
He says, that's no problem.
He says, I've looked this all up.
He says, two members of the same family cannot work.
Not only in the same department or same institution, but in the same entire system of higher education.
Except under unusual circumstances.
And he said, this is McFicker's words.
Dave relayed them to me.
He said, I regard a man on wife scientific team as an unusual circumstance.
So Dave came.
His wife was allowed to work with him.
And at the same time, Lisa was allowed to work with me.
The really remarkable and most interesting thing about this,
there was one small attempt to cover the tracks here.
And that was that Clara Schumacher had the, was responsible to me.
And Lisa was responsible to Dave for monitoring purposes.
But of course, Dave came around and said, well, he said, how is Lisa doing fine?
And I said, then he says, how's Clara doing?
I said, oh fine.
So that was the monitoring.
And of course, that all disappeared on the end.
But in retrospect, it's pretty funny.
So that's how we were able to continue.
So Lisa did a lot of computer work.
Pardon?
Lisa did a lot of computer work?
Oh, well, yeah.
But not just computer work.
She's a special expert in programming.
Yeah, that is evolved during the ages that we've been here.
But she is responsible for all the basic materials that we use in our research even today.
Some of these programs have been modified by others and even added to by others.
But the basic thing, she is responsible for.
That's very funny.
Can you reflect on their early days of using computers in your work?
Computers on work?
Yeah, well.
Yes.
When I left Caltech, we had some IBM office machines, and we were able to operate them using IBM
punched cards.
We had a very, for the time, very efficient system for doing the calculations and necessary
for our work in electron production.
When I came to Oregon State, we didn't have this IBM set up here at all.
But the mathematics department had managed to the applied aspect of mathematics here,
the very interested in computers, and the central computer by IBM had been developed
a few years earlier, and there was a computer that they managed to buy in mathematics.
It was called an all-wak-3E.
They sold a few of these things, and we had one here.
He was set up and running in mathematics and the basement.
It was a tube machine.
I mean, it was a huge thing with tapes and vacuum tubes.
Transistors hadn't been invented yet.
At least we're not available in a device like this.
And so we wrote together.
I did programming when I first came here.
There was no compiler for this machine, so we had to write things in machine language.
And I learned enough to do that and wrote the very earliest programs in machine language
that run on the all-wak-3E.
Well, they all-wak-3E as our analytical scheme improved.
The programs got more and more lengthy as far as that machine was concerned.
The machine, by this time, was beginning to teach her a bit.
And there were some graduate students over there on mathematics that managed to know what tubes
to interchange and exchange and for the keep this thing running.
But we had to write our early programs in such a way.
We couldn't rely on the machine because it would make errors due to fully hardware.
And so we wrote our programs in such a way that we could run them twice.
And if we got the same answer, we could continue to the next stage.
And these are my wrote those programs.
Then after a while, and by the way, I had some money on the use of the machine you had to pay.
So I, at one stage, gave them a few hundred dollars from one of my grants
against future computing.
So they could buy a vacuum tubes to put into this machine.
Believe it or not.
Harvard Loan Seth was a chairman of mathematics at that time.
Very nice guy.
So a couple of years later, it turned out that statistics had gotten whole of an IBM machine.
It was running on punch cards, but it had a compiler and so on and so we moved to that.
That was a central computer.
They charged also.
But it was a much better machine in the 1410, I think it was called.
And then things progressed around here.
We were still doing central computing.
There was a central computing center that was set up.
And they bought a CDC machine.
And that CDC machine was better still faster.
And by this time, we had altered our programming so that we could access the machine remotely through a telephone line.
And we had a teletime terminal in the laboratory.
So on data from our experiments could be put out on punch paper tape.
And that punch paper tape could be fed into our terminal and carried over to the computer.
We thought this was why we were really ahead of things there.
It was great.
Then it turned out that was heavy demand for that machine.
And the amount of storage we needed for some of our programs was huge.
And they didn't have enough of that, say.
So we were limited.
And to how much storage we could use in any of our programs.
So these are very, very cleverly took our biggest, most demanding programs and created it to operate with overlays.
So that instead of saving something, she determined what would be needed and wrote the program.
So succeeding stages could write right over this stuff.
And so this occurred in that way, the program became very efficient as far as space was concerned.
And then we still needed space.
So I talked to them over there and they said, oh well, you can have more space after the hours of such and such.
So we would set our stuff to run on this machine at a later time.
Then of course, that was the time that Lisa, one of the times when Lisa was hired to be working over there.
Then the central computing of course began to gradually disappear as a PCs came in.
And right away, well, before that happened in chemistry, we determined that we needed a computer locally.
And we managed to get a grant, several of us, pulled our knowledge and resources later proposal.
And we were able to buy our VACs.
And Lisa then converted all our programs to run on the VACs.
And that was tremendous.
And we have lots of programs including plotting ones.
We had a plotter, also worked just fine.
And then of course, the VACs began to be phased out.
And we had a PDP 11 in our laboratory, finally, Lisa and me.
And some of our stuff was ran on that.
But this was all very closely stuff.
And the PDP 11 used large disks like this, you know, floppy disks that were eight inches or ten inches in diameter.
Then PCs began to appear on the scene.
And so, at one stage or another, I could see that there was going to be no expertise around the hall or do anything about PDP 11's.
Everything was going to be going to PCs.
So if we wanted to keep current and not be high and dry, that if something happened to the PDE 11, nobody would know what to do.
So we converted all of our stuff to run on PCs.
And all of our data, all through the years, had been stored on these disks on the PDP 11.
Well, we hired a guy to convert all of the stuff on the PDE 11 onto disks that could in a format that can be used on a smaller, well smaller,
but faster PCs.
And these were all on floppy disks like this.
Well, pretty almost disappeared.
And we had to convert them to some other medium.
And so we took all of this stuff and copied them all over on the CDs that are now like this.
And I have a host of things on CDs.
But also a whole pile of stuff on these floppys.
All cataloged and I've maintained a couple of the PCs in my laboratory.
A floppy disk drive that will still accept these old ones.
There's no reason to change it to anything else.
But now we're going to extremely fast computers.
A calculation on the all-wack 3E would take us two days we can now do in about 10 seconds, something like that.
And there's so fast now on the storage, it's so enormous.
I can get a program going in a little hit return.
I can't get my hands on my lap before all the information is on the screen again.
It's been a total revolution.
Well, in the midst of all this, some place back we had a special tectronics scope, which could feed data in would plot things for us.
We could see it on the screen there.
And my son later went on to a electric engineering degree and it's Stanford.
And as a software engineer at Microsoft, now when he was in high school he loved these computers.
And he could program also.
And so he played it, believe it or not, a big role in some of the very early developing.
When he was at Stanford, he would come home and say, well, what do you need now down?
Still interested in that.
I should say one other thing, our kids were kind of interested in science.
And so Eric and Lisa and I published a paper together on work that he had actually worked on the laboratory.
And this is a paper by had bird had bird and had bird and had bird.
And it was published in the journal of chemical physics.
And a few years later, my daughter was interested in we published a paper.
Another one by had bird had bird and had bird.
And I never managed to get the two kids to the laboratory at the same time.
So we could have four had birds on it.
One time I called up the journal editor of chemical physics.
Well, man named Willard Stout, way back when I said, this is Ken Hedberg.
And he said, oh, of Hedberg, Hedberg and Hedberg.
Apparently, he had noticed this.
So anyway, that's more or less the story of computing.
Okay, well, the last question for today, I'd like you when we were at your office, we've seen the final folders.
And you can explain what the final folders are.
So we have an agenda.
But the final folders are.
There are several stages in the analysis of a structure.
And they begin with the raw data that we get from using this micro-densitometer.
It's a tomator on the films or plates.
And these raw data are the first things that go into the folder.
Now, a lot of things have to be done to that raw data.
Because after all, you're taking what is a continuous curve and you're sampling it at very small intervals along it.
So you have points that correspond to this.
Now, when this density plate or film moves across the densitometer, it goes across the middle and back out on the other side.
So we scan the film from one side to the other.
But all the time it's rotating, which means that half of the film should be identical to the other half of the trace.
It should be identical to the other half.
But since you're sampling by points, you can't make sure that these points are identical.
So you have to do something as we define the center.
So we have a program that compares the two sides of this and determines where the center is.
And then it takes the data on one side and that on the other.
And interpolates if necessary between the points adds them all together to give you a scan.
That's all in their finding the center.
So we have the curve in counts.
We have the curve curves that find the center.
And then we have the data we're just just numbers.
We want to convert them to something which has a common basis.
And because of the properties of the densitometer, a very black film can give you the same range of numbers that are very light-filled.
But there's obviously a lot more scattering in one than in the other.
So we have a way of converting these information to let us call it absolute densities.
It's not really that, but it really puts the two curves on the same scale in terms of darkness and so on.
Then we have a number of programs that are designed to convert this.
There is a difference between the blackness of the film and the intensity of the scattering.
Now you can get a sense of this where, for example, if you take a film and expose it for a second,
you get a certain darkness.
Suppose it for two seconds, you get another darkness.
And of course, if in the right range, the blackness of the second would be,
if you expose twice as long under identical condition, the blackness would be twice as great.
Well, clearly, the longer you expose the less the photographic film is going to respond.
So pretty soon it gets black and it doesn't matter how long you expose.
So it goes, not again, a blacker.
So the curve that relates blackness to intensity is not linear.
We have to find out how long, we know how long linear it is in terms of how dark the film is.
So we have corrections for that.
We have a whole host of corrections that are built into this that is designed to take the data from the film and put it into a form.
Which compares with mathematically with a theoretical function that we can calculate.
And there are many steps in this process.
Each one of these steps builds up to this point.
And then when we've got all of that, we then have.
We do a number of calculations.
The most important of which is the final fitting procedure.
And it's called the least squares adjustment.
And so this is a program that fits the final model to the experimental data.
And the results of that is an output in the folder that shows the fitting quality of this.
And then there are often plots of the curves at various stages of this procedure.
So it all goes into the line printer output, which those days we call the final folder.
And it might be anywhere from two inches thick.
Well, anywhere from an inch thick to three inches thick side.
And that's what you saw on those line printer folders.
Now we have almost the same thing nowadays.
But it is all done on eight and a half by 11 stuff you see.
When we're doing a hard copy that we want to look at.
But now we actually put all this stuff on a disk on a CD.
And it's all we have folders on the computer for molecules that contain all the information we want.
And some folders and some folders.
And I take these the major folder and I'll just copy the whole thing over onto a CD.
And I'll give it a name for the molecule and everything we want.
Now we can put on this CD.
Look in there.
We can find it right away.
So it's the hard copy stuff that you saw on the laboratory.
Really is stuff that we stopped generating maybe 20 years ago.
And the later stuff is all in either in folders or on hard copy or on devices like CDs.
I read recently, somebody was saying CDs are going to disappear also.
So maybe it'll all be on a thumb drive now.
Who knows.
Okay, what we've been going for an hour and a half is always the holiday today.
All right?
Good.
All right.